hallo mega kraft da ich gehört habe dass
sie gerade offene stellen anzubieten
haben würde mich hiermit als lesbierin
bewerben
schon seit meiner kindheit spiele ich
gerne spielen angefangen hat es mit
monopoly und uno aber ich habe natürlich
auch kein problem damit minecraft zu
lernen kommen wir nun zu meinen stärken
ich kann an der xbox spielen an einem
computer ich spiele auch mit der
nintendo ds oder mit der playstation
außerdem habe ich immer einen lustigen
spruch auf lager
es hat sich ausgespielt aber das ist
noch nicht alles
ich kann natürlich auch longboard
und ich kann longboard fahren und mich
dabei schminken
wenn ich mit meiner bewerbung die
interesse geweckt habe würde ich mich
natürlich über eine positive rückmeldung
freuen
mit freundlichen grüßen ihre mal werne
achso und falls sie kein interesse haben
und das unternehmen vielleicht verkaufen
wollen ich hätte ich hier noch 23 euro
und 56 cent
denn ich glaube dass selbst mein hamster
dieses netzwerk fehler führen würde